last week for this session is Rafael
oliviera
however you want
to be fun
thank you everyone thank you the the
organizers and thank you everyone for
being here
so I'm going to talk about secure
distributed matrix multiplication
uh
uh so
the setting for this problem is is quite
simple you can imagine a user who wants
to multiply
two matrices that he has and he wants to
do it quickly so he wants to use the
help of servers to accelerate the
process
however these matrices might have
private data or be correlated in some
way to some private data of his and so
he would want to do this in a way where
the servers do not learn anything at all
about what is in the matrices so
one of the applications for this could
be in a training some type of machine
learning model where these matrices are
generally correlated to your data in one
way or the other and you would want to
so generally the matrix multiplication
is the most expensive uh procedure and
and many of the algorithms that are used
so here for security we're looking at
information theoretic security and we
have this parameter T which controls the
amount of servers that we are permitting
to talk to each other well or that we
are hoping the scheme doesn't assume
that they're gonna talk to each other
but the point is that if they end up
knowing about each other it's not good
for us and so there's this parameter T
that controls that
and again the goal is to speed up the
the computational fact
of this process so
uh so Tandon and Chang were were the
ones who first looked at this and this
more information theoretic communication
type way there's been a lot of work on
this I'm just showing some stuff in
particular for for maybe for the general
audience here this work by a Westerner
on showing how to use this for machine
learning type application might be
interesting just to see how this works
in practice we also did work on this for
distributed learning on these uh like
Android devices although here the goal
was not to accelerate it was to lower
energy costs so you can think of it like
you have your little phone wants to do a
machine learning task or your smart
watch and there are these base stations
and you use them and you want to save
the power on on your phone or
or watch or or so on
um there's also some interesting work by
people here also on the differentially
private version of this problem so that
seems to be exciting
and yeah so this is some of the
literature so going back to the to our
problem uh I'll show
the simplest way of solving something
like this and then we'll talk about how
one can extend that so the simplest way
to go about this is using polynomial
codes or what could be some sort of like
generalized version of secret sharing
and so the idea is that you you take so
for this setting we're going to have our
matrices A and B and we'll have three
servers and we'll just assume that the
servers don't know who each other are so
they don't talk to each other and then
the idea is that you generate some
random matrices which are going to work
as random keys and you generate these
polynomials
so your a plus RX or B plus SX and
evaluations so the X you can think of it
as a scalar
so that you're going to send evaluation
so the user will send evaluations of
these polynomials to each one of the
servers so server one gets a plus r b
plus s so he doesn't learn anything
about the matrices A and B because they
are essentially padded by these
completely random matrices or an s
and the idea is that the servers are
going to multiply these things and send
them back to the user now when the
servers do this it's as if the servers
are evaluating another bigger polynomial
which is the multiplication of these two
polynomials
so it's this polynomial here and you can
see that the answer
that
we are interested in appears as one of
the coefficients of this polynomial so
this polynomial being of degree two you
can then if you had three evaluations of
it so this is what you're essentially
get here
each so they're essentially sending
evaluations the servers are sending back
evaluations of this polynomial here with
three evaluations you can essentially
retrieve all the coefficients of your
polynomial which retrieves what you are
interested in
and so this is one way a problem like
this could be solved
uh however now and this is the basic
fundamental idea behind many of the
other Solutions the point here is that
if you look at what is the work going on
here all the servers are essentially
doing the same amount of work of a full
big matrix multiplication
uh it's not completely useless you could
have a setting where like I said even
the user wants to save energy or
something and he just wants to Outsource
it but in terms of speeding up
computations if everyone so if even all
the servers have the same power here
like it's just gonna take you as much as
doing a matrix multiplication plus a
bunch of coding and decoding so to deal
with that you generally want to break up
the matrices into pieces
so one way you can do it is through an
outer product partitioning which is you
you break your Matrix into P so these
are all matrices also you just broke it
into sub matrices
so you break it into this way and uh so
this isn't because it's an out one could
also break it into an inner product or
other types of products I'm just going
to talk about the outer product here we
do have work on the inner product stuff
but not enough time to talk about it
here
so for our product partitioning
you can think of it you break your
Matrix a into these K pieces your Matrix
B into these L pieces and now you have a
bunch of these smaller multiplication
tasks that need to be done and you can
think of it in some way as if the
servers are gonna do one over KL of the
work and hopefully the idea is that when
you distribute this whole thing the
whole procedure will take less time than
just doing it yourself that's the
Baseline for this just do it yourself
and that's what we're we're going to
look at okay
so the first thing so again uh in the
previous on the previous example I was
showing was essentially when K and L are
equal to one where you don't do anything
you didn't partition it now what what is
going to change when you start
partitioning things into pieces well the
first thing is that you can't choose any
polynomial so before we were sort of
lazy about it where you just added a
polynomial with a key and you you put an
X there and everything worked out and
here if you try to do the same thing
here so let's say here we partition into
three pieces and we're gonna do uh
at most two servers are allowed to talk
to each other so you have that's just
gonna tell you how many keys you have to
have here for your Randomness right
so if you're just lazy about how you
choose the
the exponents here of your
your monomials here this will not work
out because you need to retrieve each
one of these individuals AI BJ so you
need to retrieve each one of these to
get your full Matrix and you can see
here that you will retrieve for example
if you retrieve the H Matrix here the h
polynomial you will retrieve A1 B1
but you're not going to retrieve A1 B2
because there's going to be some noise
from another term that sort of got mixed
up with it
so you can't just be lazy about it you
gotta do some level of design
maybe the simplest uh level of design
is this scheme here
where what you do
is
so you're sort of lazy about your F
polynomial but the G you sort of space
out the exponents so you can see here
that there's not going to be this
interference anymore because now A1 B1
appears with the exponent zero A1 B2 is
going to experience with the exponent 5.
and you're not going to have any other
exponent 5 appearing you can check that
if any multiplication here so A2 with
this guy is going to give you an
exponent one you don't have any exponent
5 interfering so you just paste out the
exponents down here and you don't have
any interference and well so this could
be one approach that one could take and
it was one of the ways that this was
being looked at which was essentially
trying to
minimize the degree of the h polynomial
because the idea was well when I was
talking before I was like oh it had
degree two so you needed three so if you
want to have the minimum amount of
servers well then just minimize that
degree of the polynomial H and what
we're going to see here is that that is
not actually the the case
so one could come up with this scheme
here
which is a little bit more funky it's
not as simple as the one above and you
can check again if you just break it all
out that you're going to be able to
decode there's not going to be an
interference A1 B1 is the only he's
going to appear with exponent zero and
nothing else is going to appear with X1
0 and so on A1 B2 so you'll be able to
decode everything he's gonna have so
when you multiply these two guys you're
gonna get a degree a polynomial H that
has
a degree of 22 which is larger than
the degree above
however
what's going to happen is that this H
star polynomial here is going to have
gaps in the degrees what do we mean by
that is there are no terms appear for
example with an exponent 13. so if you
multiply this out there is no term so
you can just look at the sums of the
exponents there's no term that's going
to appear with a 13. or a 14 or a 16 or
a 17 or a 20. which is equivalent as if
you already knew that there's a zero
there so you can so that sort of means
that you haven't like extra information
about it because of the way you designed
it
so you actually need less servers or
less interpolation points to retrieve
what you get what what you need
so if you
do out the math and so if you subtract
these points from the 22 that means that
in the end for the h star polynomial so
for scheme 2 you will actually need 18
servers instead of 19 servers for the
other one even though the degree is
higher
so just to make the point that it's not
about the degree
which then takes us to the question well
what is it about right and the idea is
just what we talked about it's about the
number of terms or non-zero terms in the
polynomial
and uh an easy way to see that is that
if I take if I gave you a polynomial of
this kind a x to the 6 b x to the fifth
CX you wouldn't need I mean obviously
with seven evaluation points you would
be able to retrieve a b and c but you
don't need seven evaluation points you
can do it with three it can't be any
evaluation points if you get F so any
seven will give you everything now you
have to be you start to have to be
careful about which evaluation points so
if you evaluate at zero you're not going
to learn anything about a b or c so
there there are these uh extra uh points
but the point is that there are there is
a way for you to retrieve it with three
evaluation points so now
so what does this say about the the like
the general problem so how can we do
things with this yes quick question so
yes say you have uh sparse polynomial
sparse in the sense that the number of
uh terms is less than the highest degree
yeah uh and you said you can of course
retrieve it with fewer number of
evaluations uh but at the end you don't
even need all the terms of that sparse
polynomial because you're only
interested in some of the terms yes and
not the others yes could you reduce it
even further yeah so that's so that's an
interesting point we don't know good
tricks for
for doing these reductions uh for this
outer problem for inner product
constructions there are tricks for doing
that by evaluating at groups of unity
and there you are able to do these
tricks for essentially you're able to
match even more together the noisy terms
that you don't care about
but
I do not know of any Roots immunity
trick and it seems to me like there
probably isn't but there for the outer
product partition thank you
but I would love to see a Roots ability
or any type of field trick for for this
problem for the outer problem version
okay so let's solve the problem in
general so again you broke it into three
by three pieces and you had two dies and
it's about essentially choosing these
Alphas so now what do we want to do
we want to so the point here is that the
h polynomial the exponents that appear
in the h polynomial are just going to be
related to the sums of the exponents
that appear in f and g so this is what
we call a degree table because it's
essentially taking the degrees of
that appear and just summing them up
together and the point is can we then
just look at this table here and just by
looking at this table no like solve our
whole problem or understand their
problem
and so the way that this works out so if
you take again our
so what what properties do they have
satisfy if we take our nice f-star and G
Star polynomial so what was happening
here you put the exponents of
of the F polynomial here so here are the
exponents of the X polynomial here the
exponents of the G polynomial or the G
Star polynomial and the h-star
polynomial is going to have terms with
these exponents and what's going to
happen is for decodability you're going
to need the red cells here to be unique
because they correspond to the things
that you want to decode so this zero
here corresponds to the A1 B1 appearing
in the H star with an exponent of zero
this tree here corresponds to the A1 B2
appearing with an exponent of 3 and you
can't have any number outside or
anywhere be the same because you would
have this interference happen so
guaranteeing that this red region is
unique is enough for you not to have
this interference phenomenon
for the security
one can show I'm not going to show here
but one can show that you just need to
choose these numbers here to be
different they can so then there's no
problem with the nine appearing here but
this 9 and 10 have to be different here
the idea is that if these if this 9 was
equal to this 9 here you it's as if you
wouldn't have two keys you just have one
of them together so but it's sufficient
to just have separate Keys is is enough
and these These are these are the
properties that you need so
uh given that uh the goal then is just
to minimize the amount of distinct
because these are going to be the
exponents that appear near H so the
amount of these distinct exponents is
just uh what you want to do if you
minimize this number so if if someone
here from the the audience uh makes a
table with numbers here so choose some
integers here choose some integers here
make them satisfy these three properties
and have them have less uh distinct
numbers than what we have here let me
know because this is the best we know so
you you just beat us and
very simple just any uh high school kid
could sit down it's just Edition tables
and and check these things easily
okay so essentially what we've done is
we have restated this whole uh secure
distributed matrix multiplication
problem into some fun combinatorial
problem which just has these tables so
just to
to restate then the goal is that if you
give us how you want to partition your
matrices in this our product form so if
you give it these parameters K and L and
what's the security parameter t
then the problem is find integers
so find K plus T integers here for one
of the polynomials L plus T integers
here such that when you just do the sum
table of them
these guys are unique these guys have to
be different these guys have to be
different and the goal is to minimize
the amount of distinct terms and that's
it
if you do one that's better than another
one it's easy to check which schemes are
better
okay so let's construct some schemes
then so the the first scheme I'll show
is what I believe to be the
laziest scheme
and I'll show why uh
because we just just put the numbers
they have to be different 0 1 2 and just
put a zero there which so you're gonna
get a zero here a one a two now the next
number you would have to put up here it
can't be zero one or two because you
would have just a repetition happening
here so just lazily go for the next
number
and continue to do that lazily go for
the next number continue to do that
uh now for sick again here you can't so
now the numbers from zero to eight you
can't use them anywhere so just go for
the next number nine there you can
repeat it there and don't even think
about it they just have to be different
just make them different one after the
other
and this is a scheme uh here I showed it
for kalt equal to 3 but it's easy to see
how you can generalize this just do this
construction and this is called gasp big
uh and the nice thing we'll get back to
that so you can then calculate how many
servers you're gonna so n is the number
of servers you'll need and it's related
to the number of regions in some way so
we can solve that and the nice thing is
that when we came up with this so here
it's number of servers versus security
level less servers is better so you
wanna so down is good so this gas big
destruction was already very good when
it when it came out
it's still very good for large T it's
the the best for large t under these uh
parameters but uh
and so the point is that okay so that
gave us this idea that the degree table
is nice in some way I mean even lazily
solving it you could do well
and then the idea is well so what's
what's good about this construction
right about this gas big
and the reason what's good about it is
so you want to have a lot of repetitions
outside of this red region
and the way that it works is that you
have these diagonals here that you can
see of repetitions that appear
and they're also appearing here right
you get this 1919 20 20 20. and the
reason these diagonals appear
is because of these uh it's because this
is an arithmetic progression with
difference one and this is also an
arithmetic progression of difference one
so you get this diagonal like every time
you go one here it's the same if you had
gone one down here so you get this here
this is sort of a mess because you get
like uh this is also an arithmetic
progression but difference three versus
one here so it's sort of it's as if you
sort of sacrifice this part to get a lot
of repetition here
and when p is very big
you're gonna get this part very big so
there's a regime where this part is very
big which is when this scheme will do
very well which is why it does very well
for for large t but the point is that
there are regimes where this is very big
and so one could potentially be like
well maybe I can then improve for that
and you can
by doing so of course if there's gas big
there's gas small
so it's for small T what's going to
happen is
instead of so do the same thing as
before for for this part here and you
get your nice repetitions here no
problem but instead of focusing here
focus on this part so now instead of
trying to match this arithmetic
progression match this one which is
three so you start with the nine just to
get because you get for free some
repetition but just go by an arithmetic
progression three here and now here you
get the diagonal stuff
and you sort of sacrifice this part but
then for a certain regime it'll do
better
of course this is just an example but
you can make these curves be as far as
as you want but the point is that so the
gas small will do better in the
beginning
that's why it's called small it's for
small T and then at some moment the gas
big will
will do much better
Okay so
uh
you can find bounds on this problem so
you and I don't have much time to talk
about how you find the bounds they're
not too complicated they're also
uh sort of lazy in some sense however
they do give you two things which is
nice they give you optimality in the
beginning
and they give you order optimality so
you're never twice away
from the optimal towards the end
so
you end up with sort of like okay so
what's going on in the middle right can
we optimize in some way in the middle or
or do better
and
so there is a generalization and if
before we were using arithmetic
progressions you just use generalized
arithmetic progressions
so this is gasp small so remember gas
small was the one where we make this guy
match with this guy here so arithmetic
progression four and you get the
diagonals here right this is gasp big
where you just make this match here and
you get the diagonals here but you have
sort of like these intermediate guys
where you sort of do this is so this is
called a generalized arithmetic
progression instead of jumping here like
by fours or jumping by ones you do this
thing where you first Jump by one then
you jump by four and then you do a jump
by one and this one is like you do oh
two jumps by one and then you do a jump
by four and they sort of get these
intermediate type things where you don't
necessarily sacrifice too much from one
side or the other and so for this
particular example K T L equal to four
the gasp two here this one has 36
servers he actually does better than
either one obviously
wants to do something there
sorry
so it is the case that there are these
intermediate regimes that do better
uh
and you have this sort of situation
where
the gasp one will do better then the
last two will do better then the gas
three will do better and then the gas
fee will do better
all the way forever and for outer
product regular partitioning this is the
current situation in terms of of what's
best
uh
the bound is not tight because
you can actually so we also we also have
results in terms of uh you can transform
the problem into a binary linear program
type search problem but it's like
infinite because potentially your your
numbers that you could choose could be
infinite right
but for certain cases we can actually
show that oh the optimal guy is not
going to be like some infinitely large
guy we can show that it's like oh if if
you have this inequality being satisfied
then the numbers that you choose will
never be larger than this and you can
make it into a finite search
and then for those parameters so for
example for k equal to l equal to 2 we
can actually NT equal to 5 we can
actually make it into a finite search
and for the finite search we can then
see that gasp 2 is the optimal and for
this particular case it doesn't match
the lower bound it's going to be an
in-between point which shows that the
lower bound is not optimal
and and yeah we we've run a bunch of
searches these computational searches
we've never we've found a lot of things
that tie with the gasp our stuff
we've never found something that beats
it but there are things that tie with it
and do not look like it which means that
maybe there's something there you know
and so on
uh I guess the the last thing I'll
comment
is okay so I was talking about uh you're
doing all of this and then there's the
problem of well is it worth it do you
actually save right so going back to the
speeding up computation right it's not
the case that it's always worth it and
this is something that one needs to be
careful about so the idea is the
following is just to make everything
two-dimensional if we fix our matrices
to just be n by n matrices
and let's make the security parameter
some constant
and now let's say that you you multiply
two matrices in time and to the Omega
and for this graph here that Omega equal
to 3 is the usual multiplication so
let's think of just do doing the usual
multiplication
and now there's a partitioning parameter
so K and L is how much you partition the
matrices now there's a parameter Epsilon
saying like how much you want to break
it up so you can think of Epsilon saying
how much you are going to break up your
matrices so the higher Epsilon is the
more work for the servers and the less
working
in some sense for yourself in terms of
the the multiplication
now what's going to happen is so if you
locally did the computation you could
always just I mean it doesn't this is
just the Baseline you're just locally
doing something that takes cubic amount
of time now what happens is that as you
start to break up the Matrix into pieces
you can lower this is the total time
complexity including communication so it
includes everything encoding sending it
out dating the notification they send it
back you do the the decoding it's the
whole time of the whole procedure
so what's going to happen is that
as you
break up the matrices into more and more
pieces
you can lower the total time complexity
but there's a minimum
and after that it starts to get worse
and it can actually get worse than what
you were doing and the analogy here is
so you can think of it so in this point
here it would be you break up the
matrices so that each server is just
doing an inner product
so if you did that each server would be
happy they just have to do nothing like
a linear operation
but you have to contact so many servers
that your decoding is just going to take
longer than just doing the matrix
multiplication yourself and this is our
analogy with real life like sometimes if
you're gonna ask help for a bunch of
people it can't be that coordinating
them takes you more than just doing it
yourself so there's a sweet spot there
and this can be calculated
and you can get so for example if
if ever if you're doing like uh cubic
complexity if you do the optimal you can
lower it from like cubic to the whole
system doing it at 2.5
right and so on and if you were to use
trust and you can also lower it so you
get this like Optimal curve in practice
uh these two points are the thing with
this one being heavily what's used but
there's more and more stressing being
used these like something like this is
for matrices that are so big that we
don't know how to implement this in in
efficient things but the point is that
it can be worth it if you choose
correctly there's there has to be some
Care on how you choose
the breaking of the stuff
and I'll just leave some open problems
like I said the bounding the entries of
the degree table could be good to solve
like we said the problem with this uh
integer programming approach uh we were
doing it through polynomial schemes
people having it is this the best way to
do it is there some other way to do it
I know linear ways to do it but they
don't beat they tie with the point I
mean polynomials are linear so by
definition they have to ties so but they
tie is there a non-linear way of doing
this I've never seen I would love to see
even if it were worse just out of
Interest I would think it would be very
cool to see
General bounds and this one can extra
computations help so here we're just
making the servers they just multiply
and do nothing else
if they do something extra can it help I
put this here because for inner product
we have work where we show that it can
help so there you can do these things
where you actually do some extra stuff
and it helps out the whole system but
for our product what I talk today is the
best I know I don't know how to do any
better than what I showed you guys today
so thank you
so we can make questions
for
this precise approach yes so the way
that this works
is
you can so what we're doing here so
there's this area of criminatorics that
worries about some sets so you have like
two sets finite sets and the subset is
all possible sums of them which is
essentially what this table is it's a
subset
and in some Theory they think about like
oh okay so you want to control the size
of and if you just have two subsets and
you want the best size you just do an
arithmetic progression and that's the
best thing to do this is a weird subset
because we have this very weird
condition here for some reason this
block has to be unique and that's why it
messes everything up so what we did is
we took a bomb from there
and we sort of like like this has to
appear there's nothing you can do about
it we sort of bounded this with the
sunset stuff and we ignored this part so
it's sort of a lazy bound
and that's where our bond comes from so
it's a Bound for this type of
construction information yeah
so that's a great question
so because this problem has an issue
for information too which is the
following and that's why so I showed one
thing that's called sdmm right and there
are many problems that they call SDM
also one of them they make the initial
user and the final user be different
and the reason is because there it makes
more sense it's easier to look at your
question because since I don't have the
information there's an information
question about how much I need to
receive but here the the uncertainty
about a times B given that I have a and
b is zero
so from a pure information theoretic
perspective
it's there's nothing to be done
so what what because the whole point is
that so so there's a computational
complexity issue
and if you even remove the the security
aspects
two complexity of metric multiplication
is a open very hard problem
this would be a generalized version of
that like an answer to that question
would be like probably an answer to even
the other question because as we saw it
even depends on how quick you can
actually do matrix multiplication just
yourself if it came out that you could
do it quadratically
then you can just do it yourself quite
rapidly right so
another interesting interaction would be
something of the form like someone like
one could ask so this is just things
I've thought about but one could think
of like oh what's the entropy of like
a times B given a and b but conditioned
on like a finite amount of operations so
some form of like
entropy but where I said like oh but
you're only allowed to do I don't know
50 computations you know you're not
allowed to do like an information to
redo everything if there was a theory of
that
which seems to be would sound like a
very hard Theory because it sounds like
uh
all about like oh you know like it's
like a comma we're all complex setting
like what is all the possible things
that one can do with this amount of
computation and you know when you
understand what I mean it's it's a it's
a complicated
getting sold in that other version where
they're separated there you can have
more definite answers than that because
then yes there's there's a precise
question so if user you have a user
intermediate servers and a final user
who wants the computation since the
final user does not have AMV one can ask
purely how much information needs to be
sent to him so that he can get it
any other questions
are the lower bounds type in that case
oh so
so
there is a complicated thing in that
case
I'll just say because you can do PIR
tricks like you can do things even with
two servers but they involve exponential
amount of computation where it says that
you can do well by breaking the like
making the whole thing take exponential
amounts of time
you know but now again in that setting
it's okay to be exponential amount of
time because user 2 does not have the
information and you're just trying to
minimize the computation but yeah
but if you care about computation yeah
it's not clear to me but maybe there the
other one sort of reduces to a PIR like
problem
any other questions
so sorry thank you
thank you thank